all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and at the time that I'm recording
this video I'm gonna be seeing black
panther 2 wakanda forever later on today
and I am hyped oh my God I'm so excited
for this movie but we are picking up
with a Fantastic Four and I timed this
specifically because Namor joined the
X-Men kind of but then like at the end
there's there's an ending to this that's
absolutely crazy right so check this out
what this does is this initially picks
up with Ben Grimm of the Fantastic Four
now remember one of the things that
we've talked about over the course of
Hickman's Fantastic Four run and as
always you'll find the playlist down in
the description so you can always go
there and get caught up but whenever Ben
Grimm goes into the forever City it
basically devolves the people that walk
in there so in the case of Ben Grimm
basically he goes through a kind of
physical change he does revert back to
his normal self but what ends up
happening here is Susan storm basically
goes on a kind of mission that we'll
talk about here in a little bit and so
ultimately Ben Grimm ends up consuming
the formula that was given to him by the
Future Foundation now again the Future
Foundation is basically the smartest
kids that work directly for Reed
Richards which is why I I say in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe right just
mark my words here in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there will probably
be a time when Peter Parker opens his
mail and there's going to be something
in there that says you are cordially
invited to join the Future Foundation if
that happens that's Reid Richards of the
Fantastic Four just know that right like
that's what the Future Foundation is but
it's the smartest people but their first
task was to basically cure Ben Grimm now
they couldn't like permanently cure him
because his exposure to the cosmic
radiation when he first became the thing
in the Fantastic Four Comics it altered
his body down to the genetic structure
right to the genetic level so all they
can really do is give them like a week
of looking normal out of every year but
of course Ben Grimm takes it now the
funny thing and for those of you guys
who are new to the Fantastic Four Ben
grim and Johnny Storm do not mistake the
banter they have back and forth for like
a genuine dislike they adore each other
right like their their brothers in every
sense of the word outside of biological
they're not actually related but they
might as well be right I mean they're
all one family so they bicker back and
forth all the time and that kind of a
thing and so where Ben Grim takes the
formula in front of Johnny Storm
Johnny's like oh my God no Ben my God
you know when Ben's just like oh my God
what's going on Johnny he's like he's
like he's so bad he's like
he's like and Ben runs and looks in the
mirror and then like he's normal
which is basically Johnny's storm
busting his balls but this is the
relationship between Johnny and Ben
right the beautiful thing about this is
that once Johnny's done giving Ben Grim
a hard time he's like look man you've
missed out on a lot of stuff right when
you were the thing you couldn't go to
different things without people looking
at you funny there's a lot of stuff that
you couldn't really experience as just a
regular guy so I'm gonna give you the
best night of your life we're gonna go
do everything I'm gonna make some phone
calls and we're gonna go have an amazing
time and it's a really cool moment and I
want you to kind of focus on this with
Johnny Storm because at the end of this
not the end of this video but like at
the end of the three story arc that
we're covering right now is the greatest
Johnny Storm moment ever in the history
of Marvel Comics oh my God it's
absolutely amazing so the thing about
this is like they kind of go out on the
town they sort of do their thing right
they go to a baseball game and in
reality like Ben Grimm has done this
stuff before he's walked around he's
gone to baseball games and so on the
people were always staring at him right
because he was the thing just this giant
rock thing and so what this means is he
can actually to sort of go out and live
his life and enjoy it without people
looking at him funny he does meet up
with Stan Lee Ben Grimm plays poker with
superheroes writes like Captain America
even Nick Fury's there which I don't
know if I'd play poker with him but what
Johnny Storm does is he takes Ben Grimm
to a final stop and he's like we're here
and Ben Grim's like where in the world
are we at which is basically Alicia
Master's apartment now Alicia Masters
for those of you guys who don't know
she's one of the most important
characters when it comes to the to the
Fantastic Four in Marvel Comics
historically speaking in terms of like
their greatest stories Alicia Masters
for example was the first one to
discover like Adam Warlock different
things like that like the fact that she
was kidnapped and taken to Adam Warlock
because he was just too bright for them
to be able to see him so she basically
Felts his features and then basically
you know made like a kind of molding of
his face but uh but she's blind right
and so for her and Ben Graham one of the
things that had always gone on is they
always had a romantic relationship but
because of the fact that Ben Grimm was
the thing there was always that part of
him that kind of held back because the
reality was he was kind of ashamed of
how he looked in front of her right
which was one of the things that really
made Ben Grimm highly relatable in
Marvel Comics because while not all of
us are walking around with Rocky skin
some of us are overweight or some of us
are underweight or some of us are
perfectly healthy weight but because of
what we're struggling with on a mental
level we just don't see ourselves as
being attractive to other people right
and so then Grimm was a great way to for
us to kind of relate to that kind of
person if that's a part of life that you
deal with and so when Ben Graham
ultimately meets with Alicia masters of
course he greets her and you know he's
like yeah it's me and she's like cool
you know when she's like why do you
sound so down and then she goes to touch
his face and realizes he's human and the
two of them are able to share an
intimate moment together which they
never would have been able to do had
been Grim stayed the thing and so of
course Johnny Storm's kind of like good
on you Ben Grimm now it's cool we got
that sentimental moment now to the good
so here's the thing right so what this
does we pick up with Susan storm right
Susan storm goes on her Mission and she
travels to Utopia now for those of you
guys who don't know Utopia is the island
that the Fantastic Four took up
residence on following the events of
dark rain right so dark brain and Marvel
Comics was a story where basically
Norman Osborne the Green Goblin had
taken over as director of shield and
then basically started gunning for all
the superheroes and trying to get rid of
them so in order to operate both outside
the jurisdiction of Norman Osborne as
well as within the realm of the United
States as superheroes that the mutant
population the X-Men were basically
given Sanctuary on an island called
Utopia off the coast of San Francisco so
basically they could kind of operate in
both worlds that's where they reside at
the time this story is being written and
so once Susan storm arrives here one of
the things that kind of goes on is Susan
storm and Emma Frost meet each other now
here's the thing to understand you don't
necessarily see the Fantastic Four
across paths with a mutant population
all that often if we're talking about a
hierarchy of social status Susan storm
is pretty high above Emma Emma Frost and
Emma Frost isn't too happy about it
right it's like Emma Susan one of the
things I learned when I was younger
right when I was younger talking to my
sister and so on women can be catty man
but as guys it's kind of hard to pick up
on it's kind of hard to pick up on that
thing and the reality is I remember my
sister telling me you don't really need
to pay pay attention to like what women
say to each other in order to figure out
how catty they are what you have to do
is you have to listen to how they say it
man because if you pick up on how they
say stuff man
man stuff that goes on man and it's like
bro it's kind of crazy but the thing
about this is that ultimately this place
was chosen as kind of a neutral
territory and the reason why is because
name of the Submariner is a mutant and
ultimately it's Susan storm meeting with
name with a Submariner so they can meet
with the rest of the atlanteans now
again playing a little bit of ketchup
here for those of you guys who are
joining us as always I highly advise you
check out the playlist in the
description after this video so you can
get caught up on everything but remember
one of the things that we learned is
that you do have the main Kingdom of
Atlantis on Earth in the Marvel Universe
but there ended up being small sections
of Atlantis that were discovered that
nobody ever really knew about and so
this is quite literally a parlay it's a
meeting between the king of old Atlantis
or this other Atlantean Colony below
vostok Lake and name or the Submariner
in an effort to see if it's possible to
find a way for both kingdoms to mutually
exist now what ends up going on here
right following this we transitioned to
Reed Richards right now Reed Richards is
on top of the Baxter building and he's
basically analyzing the fault now all
those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with that and I imagine
probably a lot of you who aren't in
Marvel Comics you basically had two
stories running between the mid to late
2000s right so between 2005 2006 running
up to about 2010 up to 2015. you had two
different sections of Marvel happening
the first one was everything on Earth
secret Invasion Civil War House of M all
that kind of stuff then you had
everything out in space Annihilation
Annihilation Conquest the war of Kings
realm of Kings all that kind of stuff so
literally it was just two different
Landscapes one of the things that had
gone on during war of Kings is that
black bolt of the Inhumans who sucks he
ended up going to war with uh basically
Vulcan the third brother of Cyclops that
nobody ever knew about who was leading
the Shia Empire this war was pretty
massive in scale a bomb was detonated
out in space and it ripped a Fisher open
in space itself at the time this story
is being written we don't know what's on
the other side now we did find out in a
story called The Thanos imperative which
we have covered and basically it's the
cancer verse a super uh I'm sorry a
universe where no one in that Universe
can die because they killed mistress
death but the the reality here is that
story as amazing as it was again hadn't
necessarily come out at the time that
the story is being written right and and
the kick out of this is that while Reed
Richards is basically analyzing This And
discussing this this voice comes out of
nowhere that says you have more pressing
matters than stargazing this evening
matters involving Galactus right the
Silver Surfer has arrived on the scene
now remember in the last video we
covered the Silver Surfer discovered the
body of Galactus from the future who'd
been brought to the past and then killed
Reed Richards more or less hid it right
and so there's a little more to his
motivation than that which we'll find
out you know in another video but the
thing about this is that like literally
Reid Richards is just like hey what's
going on knowing rad it's been a little
while you know how are you doing and
Silver Surfers like I'm very very pissed
off I found what was hidden below the
surface of the Earth and the responsive
readers I don't know what you're talking
about Silver Surfer right Norman Rad's
response my brother in Christ I can tell
that it was you right like you literally
have a unique Cosmic signature and it
was all all over this body right like
you might as well have stuck a sign with
giant purple letters that said Fantastic
Four were here right that's what it
might as well have been and so once The
Jig Is up right then Reid's kind of like
okay I can explain I mean I can explain
it to you but it'd be kind of difficult
to explain to you but it would take time
for me to do that's when the Silver
Surfer is like no no no you
misunderstand me Reed it is my master
who seeks answers to difficult questions
and he would have them now now you know
what guys I'm in such a good mood
because I'm going to see wakanda forever
let's keep his story gone so what this
does is this basically like like
Galactus is madder than hell this guy's
pissed and he literally snatches up Reed
and he's like explain now here's the
thing to understand about this right
when it comes to Galactus and Marvel
Comics there's been two eras of Galactus
the one you take seriously and the one
you don't in more recent years Galactus
is the one who's just kind of there and
he's more or less a punching bag for
people and that's it at the time this
story is written man this is the
Galactus you take seriously when this
dude shows up shit's about to pop off
that's it's litter it's it's an absolute
thing right it's an absolute rule of the
universe right just the way it is Omega
Level mutants are really overpowered
Black Bolt and the Inhumans suck
Galactus is a guy you take seriously
right it's a rule you don't argue with
it and so as soon as Reed is told to
explain he immediately offers an
explanation no ifs ands or buts there's
no beating around the bush none of that
stuff right he literally says in the
future on a dying Earth a collection of
the remaining heroes and villains
created a machine to open a hole in
space and time and send the roughly 1
billion survivors of the human race back
here for this to work they needed an
immense energy source so at Great cost
they captured you and executed their
plan siphoning what they needed from
your body to power their device as a
result they were all transported back
through time and you die they literally
burned your body out they burned your
life force out getting themselves back
here and he says the surfer founder
remains deep beneath the Earth because I
bury them there I was I was not trying
to be deceptive it just seemed wrong not
to and so that's when Silver Surfers
like where are they right and that's
when Reed's like oh they're basically
far away on an artificial Earth
circulating uh circling a star on the
other side of a galaxy right like a
decaying star basically a star that's
turning into a black hole that's when
Galactus is like located right and as
soon as that happens Silver Surfers like
it's right over there and Galactus is
like let's go right so that's that's the
thing now here's something that I want
you guys to notice right and we're going
to get an explanation about this because
I'm gonna tell you right now Galactus is
crapping his pants he is terrified right
he's scared as hell and we'll find out
why here in a second because it's
amazing it's like this is amazing
Revelation that happens with the
Fantastic Four other times it's so
phenomenal we'll talk about it here in a
second because it's hilarious right now
Johnny Storm does show up because of
course you know Galactus is hovering
over New York it's enough attention for
anybody and so that's when he's kind of
like do we need to respond to this and
the response to Galactus is no right I I
have no intention of attacking your
world right I'm leaving right now at
this very moment I'm literally getting
off of Earth as fast as I possibly can
and we're gonna travel to this
artificial world and then we'll
basically find answers there and he
literally says this this is one of the
most important things Galactus says he
says you will attend me Reed Richards
until this and other matters are
resolved the other matters that's why
Galactus is hauling ass off of this
world man that's why he's booking out of
here as fast as he can right so
ultimately Reid ends up going with
Galactus right Silver Surfers told go to
that world prepare for my arrival that
kind of a thing Galactus and and Reed
are like they basically bail out as fast
as they can now here's one of the cool
things that happens here right and we'll
we're gonna we're gonna transition back
to that Galactus moment here in a second
yes someone to make you wait on it
because there's something really really
cool that happens in between right so
what we end up doing is picking up with
Susan storm once she's met with name or
the Submariner and they're basically
here in the Central Pacific Basin having
this meeting with uh basically the other
king of Atlantis now the thing about
this is that you do have uh Namor second
in command Andromeda and of course she
doesn't trust Susan storm and the reason
why is because one Susan storm is a
Surface dweller and in Marvel Comics
much like Aquaman and the DC Universe
atlanteans do not trust people on the
surface and so she ultimately believes
Susan storm is leaning Neymar into a
trap now one of the most important
things to understand here about the
relationship between Namor and Susan
storm is that they've banged kind of not
really they basically have but Marvel's
never really confirmed it I don't think
but like there's been instances where
Susan storm more or less stepped out on
Reed Richards with Namor but at the very
least it's one of these things where
like Namor is very much interested in
Susan storm so that's why you see her
kind of getting special treatment and
that's why under any normal circumstance
never with a Submariner would absolutely
Grill and question everything he's being
told by somebody from the surface who's
saying it's in your best interest to
have this meeting with this other king
of Atlantis and to hear what they have
to say or at least this other Atlantean
Kingdom that exists out there to hear
what they have to say but with Susan
storm he's like you know what I trust
you Susan mostly because I'm trying to
get you between the sheets but the thing
about this is like he's like you know
let's let's roll with it and let's see
what happens now during this meeting
that takes place it's this kind of
amazing moment right because the reality
is the entirety of these of this meeting
is just going south Namor and his main
Atlantean kingdom do not want to give up
virtually anything they're agreeing to
like compromise but like if we're
talking about percentages it's like
they're willing to give up 10 of
anything they have right in reality it's
territory it's what areas get governed
what areas are overseen what area
belongs to like Neymar's Kingdom what
area belongs to this this other King's
Kingdom that kind of thing right you
know it's a war of Kings and the the on
the oceanic level you do have some
attempts to make make this whole
negotiation process work but what's
really funny is that in all of this
right like this King literally just
starts becoming just so irritated right
he's like this negotiation process is
becoming untenable right like we all
breathe the same water you guys are not
willing to give up any territory
whatsoever and the result of this is
like there really doesn't seem any point
in being here at these negotiations and
the responsive name or is like while you
slept the world changed Old King and it
changed for the better he says I agree
to this meeting so that I could see your
face so I could see for myself exactly
what had awakened from a dark long time
ago and now that I have my course has
been set and this guy's like okay like
what in the world are you talking about
he was a name or name of the Samaritan
man here's the thing let me tell you
something man in Marvel Comics there's
like 25 fans in the name of the
submarine let's be honest with ourselves
right I mean it's easy it's cool kind of
sometimes I guess this is one of those
moments when he's boss right he's like
this is my answer to your demands he
throws his spear across the room kills
the King on spot right and then it's
just like this is my answer compromise
never and then just start stabbing
everybody to death he kills them blood
just starts killing all the leadership
of the uh of like this other Kingdom
he's like I ain't compromising for [ __ ]
right he literally says that that there
is only one king under the sea and
that's me name of the Submariner either
you will bow before me or you will die
that's the thing man name is a
Submariner man this guy is next level
sometimes right this guy's a boss now
get into the part that you guys all
wanted to get to right before you guys
all wanted to see I told y'all man John
and Hickman's Fantastic Four songs I
told you man dude this this [ __ ] was lit
it's absolutely amazing right so here's
the thing what ends up happening here is
that Galactus takes Reed Richards to his
ship ta too now for those of you guys
who don't know anything about Galactus
Galactus comes from a from a universe
that's basically dead the previous
universe but in that Universe his
Homeworld was called tah he ended up
creating a new home called tattoo right
so it's like a tribute to his old place
now here's the thing this is what's so
important right Galactus says as soon as
my Herald returns with the others we
will depart immediately for this new
world now the responsive read is what
others and Galactus simply says there
were several other beings on your world
that had prolonged exposure to the same
particles found on my remains and he's
in the responsive read is like not my
family and the response of Galactus is
no others right we'll find out what that
means later on but he says but the
response of of Galactus is it is not
lost on me that you have a universally
relevant intelligence read Richards
meaning you are intelligent on a
universal level and everybody in the
universe respects how smart you are
because Reed is arguably the smartest
person in the entirety of the Marvel
Universe and Galactus asks you notice
how rapidly we left your planet and the
responsive read is I did it was
inconsistent with your established
protocol of energy conservation
especially now knowing the surfer will
collect to others that will probably
need secondary Transportation but
considering my relatively small sample
size when compared to your overall
longevity I thought it best to continue
observation silently now this is where
Galactus spills the beans and this is
what's so amazing because I'm getting
ready to leave you guys on a cliffhanger
from hell right so he literally says
right now my primary goal is the
prevention of my unnatural demise my
unnatural death but we left because I
feared the outcome of a potential
confrontation if I had stayed on Earth
and reads like you were afraid and the
response of Galactus is the blocks in
his mind have been broken and his powers
are active again read Richards we have
to talk about your son we need to talk
about Franklin Richards with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end cliffhanger's son I'm gonna go
see wakanda forever later on today we'll
be back next Thursday thank you all for
watching I will catch you all later
peace